this has become a familiar yet still
painful routine for gin Tala
it's the fourth time she's had one of
her calves taken from her
the latest 18-month old moon shoe is
tethered to another adult and taken away
tied to a tree is clearly distressed
crying out for her mother the video some
of which is too disturbing to show we
shot secretly at an elephant training
school in the province northeast of the
Thai capital Bangkok the techniques and
punishments such as being beaten or
prodded with metal hooks while being
forced to walk while their legs are
bound together and designed to make them
compliant or in the end to entertain
tourists many want a close encounter
with one of Thailand's national symbols
or another animal for years ago one of
the most popular wildlife attractions
the tiger temple was raided and closed
because of allegations the owners were
trafficking big cats and animal parts
soon after the park was given permission
to reopen elsewhere these elephants that
are among thousands captive in Thailand
will also be heading to parks and zoos
but the corona virus pandemic has meant
the tourism industry here has ground to
a halt almost 200 animal welfare
organizations wrote to the Thai
government asking them to use the
opportunity to reset the industry
they've heard nothing back and also
ensure that the current generation al
Jazeera also approached the Tourism
Authority of Thailand for reaction to
the video but it declined the concern is
that when the borders reopen operators
will be desperate to make up
for lost revenue and the elephants will
be trained and put to work harder than
ever Wayne hey al Jazeera Bangkok